hey friends give a warm welcome to the
newest member of my plucky family
this is a brand new classical guitar by
sayer's guitars it's a toraz replica
which i've had before but this is a
special one because it goes by the name
targa and if you know my youtube channel
you might know that i love the music by
the 19th century romantic spanish
composer uh francisco targa so i think
it's fitting that i have this targa
model guitar by sayers it's one of their
masterworks
guitars m800 t
so this is a model that
is for sale and what's so cool about it
is that they have really went out of
their way to kind of age it this is
flame maple which is normally very
golden and yellow but it looks very um
honey like and kind of rich and dark and
the sound board is spruce but it looks
quite dark and golden as well which is
kind of what you get when a guitar ages
over a long period of time maybe you
even recognize it from the video i did
playing a 275 000 guitar
[Music]
that was an original torres guitar uh
from the late 19th century so it looks
surprisingly similar and quite uh
beautiful and of course the sound is
very rich
and of course i fitted the guitar with
sheep intestine gut strings just like
targa would have played
for me that extra effort goes quite a
long way towards getting a 19th century
sound as opposed to a 21st century sound
somehow synthetic strings really just
don't have as much character and
personality i think if you want to learn
more about gut strings on a guitar you
can watch my video where i cover that
subject at length i think today
guitarists are so obsessed with volume
that they put super super high tension
strings on and as a result the music
suffers and the guitars sound a bit
two-dimensional tora's guitars had a
magic to them they're rich
and yet
clear and they don't scream at you they
pull you into their world in a charming
way and that's for me why the tourist
guitar is so cool
it's resonance but not overpowering
[Music]
so you'll be seeing lots more of this
beautiful new target guitar on my
channel probably strong in gut
for now let's hear a full piece by targa
this is one of my favorites that i've
never actually done a full recording of
his piece adelita
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you